this is day one of jacob's writer's
retreat we are out in Malibu California
here to do one thing and one thing only
and that is to write our movies all they
know we've been trying to make this
movie since 2014 p.m. add much progress
on it due to many different factors
including dependent key popular YouTube
channel from JK news JP party to the
business that kind of goes in and out of
all that which has been really tied down
and so we've actually decided to camp
out all that noise but removing
ourselves from LA cannot Malibu to
isolate ourselves and to get some
progress that on this movie and you
might be thinking well it's been three
years now since you guys announced
you're gonna make a movie and when Dan
out yet precise three years neither me
part or Joe could agree on idea that all
three of us like and we were actually
struggling a lot of different concepts
we even like tried making some of these
concepts and you know midway through
writing we were like uh we don't really
care about this anymore it's one of
those things like you start something
you kind of lose a little fire along the
way and just decide not to do it anymore
and I happen with all the other stories
it's not that we lost fire for this film
we lost fire for the story when it comes
to making movies and filmmaking at the
core of it you know we're storytellers
and we need to find a unique and
interesting story that is compelling for
us to want to tell and now with
something we really struggle to find and
I think we finally landed on an idea
that we're all pretty passionate about
so it's just me Bart and Joe we're going
to spend the next three days out here
trying to write this movie again and
give you guys a tour of the house over
it so this is my room
so this para nice little bathroom all to
myself and then this is the cool part
we're going to go outside I think my
room was designed for a nanny or a maid
right outside my room is the utility box
lots of storage area and extra mattress
and also it's not very pretty I got that
extra room that has its own bathroom so
I imagine this is like the live-in nanny
works here and list here and the only
way to my room is through this door
[Music]
it's gonna be a wonderful morning look
at that look at that
[Music]
I'll get the homie right here hanging up
on my broom yesterday when we got in it
saw that guy for the first time I
thought was the body just hang there
[Music]
alright so maybe view because of how
amazing it is we're hoping that we'll
create some sort of creativity for us to
make this move yesterday we're going to
do a lot of the heavy lifting and
hopefully we'll get a huge chunk of
hanging the script writing at the
scripting say to rat the outlining phase
right now
hopefully we'll not got majority the
outlining all we're going to do is write
cook workout repeat and hopefully I can
get rid of this wife beater tan I've
chronic wife beater ten problems
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we have a breakfast bar
first with lemon on the counter because
of try to record a video that makes
these happen at the same time I don't
see what I'm doing so more lemon Atacama
dinners on this fruit I think on this
camera view on that camera trio now the
behind the scenes of our Father here so
far was making fun of me earlier for
crossing over to the next to dark side
so would be a Gio you didn't talked over
to the Mexican dark side at all I do but
we don't have this at home I only deal
when I saw the fruit there's other side
of the street now growing up I've been
trained by my parents to think that
fruits need to be fundamentally sweet in
order to be a quality fruit so and I met
this and she introduced me to the way
Mexican do fruit they don't like sweet
fruits necessarily we can be good but
then they'd rather have it salty spicy
and sour over sweetness it's a little
more mouth-watering than sweet fruit
though actually it comes to like it a
lot morning let me father reason amazes
very unhealthy
it's more law action now serving it wall
to the disk rule the maiden shot whoa
look at this me wave Loftus Russ
everyone's recording all of this just
for this yeah
that's your breakfast alright so we got
our breakfast ready
happy Father's Day to my dad and me from
my mom cool holiday today I'm considered
a father now oh he doesn't morning
really bad I had that make you feel
automata how to stomp on around the
concept of being the father but like I
haven't put it'll work you know I
haven't like licensed s or like take her
to school or any of those things
true anyways we're going to start
writing up fine we're due to
international work out on my stay in our
marriage Hollywood over to face all the
food we are we have to that's the rule
we can't leave it like this foot ten the
company training yeah we got zucchini I
did there's like mystery items at il got
Vegas but they going on right now so I
have been tasked to do right
how much rice are going to eat I don't
know are we getting up to Marcel true
alright well I'm going to go with the
big pot of rice I grew up learning how
to make rice on the stove dances yeah
okay never tell you guys a story so the
reason why I know how to make right on a
stove it's because my mom when she
cooked sometimes she's a little
forgetful and she'll forget to turn on
the rice cooker even when the rice is
washed and in the actual cooker almost
like maybe once a week we would cook
rice on the stove and I would just see
it and watch it not just like oh that's
how you cook rice the old-fashioned way
and so I'm about to do that right now
and I don't realize how rare it was to
cook rice on the stove so
got a pot that right and measuring cup
of rice this is the closest thing I
could find that looks like that you know
the right scooper that comes with the
rice cooker usually they get the golden
rule is the one per person to you guys
gonna have leftover oh okay
three or just double up just by clicking
rice and our nice butchers you wash the
rice I used to watch my write three
times
are you supposed to wash it until it's
clear that I don't have time for that I
never wash all right so just like
regular right or like the way you would
make write in a bread closures first
knuckle of your finger perfect once you
got your rice to wash and you got the
cooking water in there and turn the fire
on turn it up high bring it up to a boil
and once it's at a boil you reduce the
heat down to low and you let it simmer
for like 15 minutes and it's all done in
fat so cool the only difference between
a rice cooker and cook it on the stove
is that you actually control the heat
yourself because the rest rigor does
that for you and fifty minutes later you
got nice fluffy rice
dangerous as to what me about Chinese
cooking did that it dangerous if the
fire hasn't yet like no other cuisine
cooking that it like ever fight back and
I pop the oil in your face Chinese food
is like be careful for the firefighters
to come
alright the Rice's comes to a boil they
hear that now they're too low I'm also
making some chicken breast with some
spinach in front through some sort of
spicy chicken with honey on a bed of
finish even though there's way too much
chicken in ratio to the spinach
[Music]
I'm actually really proud of ourselves
mark was saying it looks like a
Thanksgiving feast it kind of does oh
[Music]
yeah Farah killed it
Oh mom a little bit yes all right
literally 24 hours has had this cameras
been on we've been writing all day got a
lot done today ever eating again and
it's dinner tonight we feast on we got
ass Fergus we got collard greens
zucchini we got think we got scripts
there we got kabob and we got write that
we got coca-cola for those who want to
live a little bitter laugh surf and turf
[Music]
awesome nice are you nervous
grilling on the people stage oh I know
it's like so much pressure
yeah and if you're not used to the grill
- so how you going to get the
medium-rare hospital just like the state
in the matrix right man I just want to
this paper I know this steak doesn't
exist I know that's really big that's
pretty awesome all right it is 3m the
vlog right now it might seem like open
about food and the food's been amazing
the house has been amazing this trip has
been amazing yeah we got a lot done
today and I think this is actually the
furthest we've ever gotten on any
feature film idea and if you have ever
had we haven't started scripting yet but
it's all been outlining but like you
know we go through multiple passes of
outlining like the first patch is very
rough like kind of like getting very
broad strokes of what would happen in
this movie with each pass we kind of go
back in more and more detail and each
pass we create more and more characters
more and more locations more and more
backstory more and more reasons why
characters do this and that and really
breaking down the psychology of
everything the one thing we don't want
is
to have a movie that features very
generic storylines and generic
characters that are very one-dimensional
and that's something that we're really
trying to avoid when creating
multi-dimensional characters you know we
have to kind of dive into the psychology
and and that's kind of hard I mean just
kind of wrapping your brain around
someone else's mind and thoughts and and
desires is a complicated just focus on
one but then to have like you know ten
characters really have to kind of
understand all ten of them at the same
time and they're always pushing and
pulling in different directions it gets
to be a very complicated process I know
there's you know this has been in the
works for three years already it might
not seem like much but you know on our
end of things and what we know about the
movie and what we're planning it's very
very big steps that we've taken this
trip when it comes to making YouTube
videos or just you know small video
small project either a blog or music
video yet they're very very basic even
the story itself oftentimes it's very
one-dimensional and YouTube's gist
you usually start with an idea like
what's so unique so what's a novelty
idea about a certain topic and like
Asian parents are funny and that's a
novelty thing and all the accents you
know you have that one thing and then
people as many jokes out of it as
possible and then that's a day's work
whereas writing a feature film it's very
complicated and the way I feel about
making short form videos it's like I
feel like a lion and then when it comes
to making this feature film you know I
feel like I'm a baby giraffe learning to
walk for the first time so it's like
it's both exciting and scary so we're
just kind of learning along the way and
we're making lots of mistakes but
mistakes are good I guess right mistakes
you you always learn for your mistakes
or whatever and we'll see what happens
tomorrow I don't know what I don't know
if I'm going to vlog anymore just it's
becoming the same thing over and over
again oh it's just not sharing any of
the writing stuff and it's just eating
stuck in a house we'll see
this might be the last thing all right
monumental moment just happened here in
Malibu California on Tuesday June 20th
2017 at 6:22 p.m.
and that is we finished our outline from
the movie but it's my America this is
the three years of making the critical
next step is script and Trust dialogue
and will continue progress we'll see how
long that takes
definitely not three years oh it's a
great day and it's been a cloudy the
last couple days it's almost as if
nature knew that we were going to finish
the outline today and it decided to be
sunny today watch out
[Music]
Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]